[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من النيابه عاصمه
النيجر وتجمع نحو 20 الف شخص دعما
للانقلاب غداه قراري طردي سفير فرنسا
ننتقل الى الخرطوم التي شهدت اليوم اندلاع
حريق كبير في مستودع وقود للطائرات في
المطار
والى بيروت على وقع بدء اعمال التنقيب عن
النفط والغاز في حقل قانا تحديات سياسيه
واقتصاديه في لبنان
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
رئيس اكواس يدعو قاده الانقلاب في النيجر
للاستجابه لمطالب بعوده النظام الدستوري
ويحذر من تدخل اطراف خارجيه عسكريا في حال
الرفض واشنطن توفد مسؤوله للمنطقه لبحث
سبل التسويه
على وقع معارك ضاريه في الخرطوم البرهان
يواصل تفقد جبهات القتال في اول جوله خارج
الخرطوم منذ اندلاع المعارك ومع تدهور
الاوضاع في نيالا بدرفور واشنطن تحمل
الدعم السريع مسؤوليه
وتطالب بوقف القتال وتامين خروج المدنيين
[موسيقى]
روسيا تعلن اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات احداها قرب
موسكو وكيف تعلن تدمير مسيرتين روسيتين
يعتبر المواجهه في اوكرانيا الخيار الوحيد
ويصفها بالحرب الوجوديه لروسيا وصحيفه
الجارديان تكشف عن مباحثات بين قائد في
النيتو وقاده عسكريين اوكرانيين لاعاده
ضبط استراتيجيه العسكريه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مواصله قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان جولاته على
قوات الجيش خارج الخرطوم والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي دلالات جولات
البرهان خارج الخرطوم للمره الاولى منذ
بدء المعارك قبل اكثر من اربعه اشهر وقد
جاءت النتيجه كما يلي نحو 54% قالوا ان
الجولات تشير الى دعم معنوي للقوات في حين
قال 18% انها محاوله لنقل المعارك خارج
الخرطوم اخيرا صوت
28% لصالح القول بالسعيد ترتيب تسويه
محتمله
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في ظل معاناتي اكثر من 100 الف باكستاني
تحذير من اتساع رقعه الفيضانات بعد تصريف
الهند كميات كبيره من المياه عبر انهار
مشتركه
[موسيقى]
طالب عدد من انصار المجلس العسكري الحاكم
في النيجر القوات الفرنسيه بالرحيل عن
بلادهم ياتي التجمع الذي نظم في الملعب
المركزي بعد مرور شهر على الانقلاب الذي
اطاح بالرئيس محمد بازوم من سده الحكم
انصار المجلس العسكري يحتشدون في استاد
العاصمه نيامه للتعبير عن وقوفهم الى جانب
المجلس العسكري
ومساندته
للتصدي لما يسمونه هنا بالهيمنه الفرنسيه
على النادى الشعارات المرفوعه هنا تطالب
بضروره توسيع التعاون مع بلدان مثل مالي
وبوركينا فاسو وروسيا ايضا كما يشيدون
بالقرارات التي اتخذها المجلس ضد فرنسا
ومصالحها في النيجر ويقولون ان العقوبات
التي فرضتها مجموعه بلدان غرب افريقيا على
المجلس العسكري بعد خطوه اللقاحه بالرئيس
محمد بازون هي عقوبات ضد الشع ب في النيجر
ولذلك يطالبون المجلس العسكري بمواصله
الوقوف ضد هذه العقوبات وعدم الاستجابه
للقرارات التي تطالبه بضروره التنحي عن
السلطه واعاده تسليمها الى الرئيس محمد
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
قال رئيس نيجيريا الرئيس الحالي لمجموعه
اكواس بولا احمد تينوبو قال ان الحربه
ليست مثاليه لمنطقه غرب افريقيا لكن
الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه امر مقدس وخلال
لقائه مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للشؤون الافريقيه مولفيه بالعاصمه ابوجا
اكد تينوفو انه يبذل قصار جهده لتسويه
القضيه سلميا في النيجر من خلال الاستفاده
من الادوات الدبلوماسيه تصريحات رئيس
اكواس تاتي بعد ان كشفت وسائل اعلام في
نيجيريا تحذيره من ان عدم تجاوب عقاده
الانقلاب في النيجر مع اكواس سيفتح الباب
لتحرك اطراف اخرى خارجه عن سيطره المنظمه
هل باتت ساعه الصفر للتدخل عسكري لمجموعه
اكواس مساله وقت في النيجر تساؤل تبرره
حاله تصعيد فقياده اركان الجيش في النيجر
امرت بوضع القوات المسلحه في حاله تاهب
قصوى
رئيس مفوضيه اكواس قال انه ليس للمجموعات
خطه لغزو النيجر لكن اللجوء الى خيار
استخدام القوه لا يزال مطروحا على الطاوله
نؤكد هنا ان الجماعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا لم تعلن الحرب على شعب النيجر
وليس لديها خطه للغزل
كتبت قبل ايام ان التدخل العسكريه في
النيجر محكوم عليه بالفشل فاستخدام القوه
لازاحه المجلس العسكري في النيجر قد يؤدي
الى ازمه لاجئين وحرب اقليميه تدخل محفوف
اذا بمخاطر اذ يجد قاده الانقلاب مالي
وبوركينا فاسو ضمن داعمهم وقد حصلت على
موافقه على انتشار قوتهما في النيجر
لمساعدتها في صدمه وصفته بالعدوان والى
جنبهم غينيا الرافضه للتدخل وفي المقابل
ابدت السنغال وبنين ونيجيريا استعدادها
للمشاركه في القوه العسكريه وتعاهد الرئيس
كوت ديفوار بمشاركه الف ومئه من جنوده في
هذه القوه ولا يستبعد ان تنخرط تشاد ايضا
في ذلك اما الجزائر التي تتقاسم مع جاريها
الجنوبي حدودا طويله ومصالح اقتصاديه
وشواغل امنيه فتعارض العمل العسكريه بشده
لكنها تريد منح الاولويه القصوى
للدبلوماسيه وفيما يبدو محاوله لتهدئه
تحفظ اطراف في اكواس للتدخل او فدت
الجزائر وزير خارجيتها في جوله الى
نيجيريا وبنين وغانا توحيد جهودنا لترقيه
اسس حل سلبي يجنب هذا البلد والمنطقه
برمتها
تداعيات التصعيد المحتمل للاوضاع
الدبلوماسيه ايضا مع استعدادات التدخل
ترافق تصريح لافتين لرئيس نيجيريا الرئيسي
الحالي لمجموعه اكواس عن ضغوط يتلقاها
بشان استعداد بعض الاطراف والدول للتدخل
عسكريا فالى من يلمح الرجل وبلده تبدو
المعنيه بشكل اكبر باي تدخل محتمل كلامه
ياتي في ظل سيناريوهات المحتمله ومتداوله
لهذا التدخل
بينها تدخل بري عبر حدود النيجر مع
نيجيريا او بنين او كليهما والتحرك عبر
بضع طرق سريعه الى اليامي وهو خيار صعب
عمليا ويطرح خيار ثاني بانزال جوي واقامه
جسر طيران عسكري لاحتلال مطار العاصمه
النيامي وبقيه المطارات ومن ثم التحرك نحو
المؤسسات الحيويه والاساسيه او عمليه بريه
خاطفه بقوه ارضيه من القوات الخاصه اقل
حجما تكون اسرع في التجميع ويرجح ان تركز
على الاستيلاء على المواقع الامنيه
والاداريه الرئيسيه وقد يكون احد الخيارات
الذي يبدو مع الوقت اضحى صعبا دعم محدود
لانقلاب المضاد لا تخفى على كل هذه
الخيارات مواقف الدول الكبرى وفي مقدمتها
فرنسا ومع حاله التوتر القائمه بينها
وقاده الانقلاب سيبدو رهان ايضا عليها
الامتلاكها قوه عسكريه جاتمه على ارض
النيجر ويمكن ان تكون عنصر ارتكاز لدعم اي
تدخل عسكري
انضموا الينا من الياما عبد الله ابو بكر
رئيس منظمه النيجر اولا ومن ابوجا الجنرال
هري ايولا الرئيس السابق للتطوير الدفاعي
بوزاره الدفاع النيجيريه وزميل كليه
الدفاع الوطني في النيجيريا سيد هذه عندما
يقول الرئيس رئيس نيجيريا ان الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه امر مقدس ولكن كيف سيتم ذلك
كيف سيتم الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه باي وسائل
اذا كانت الحرب غير مثاليه
كان رئيس الاكواس
والتالي يعتبر الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه امر
مقدسا هذا هو السؤال اليس كذلك كيف ما
ورينا بذلك
سيد هنري انا اتساءل عن الادوات والوسائل
[موسيقى]
ان اي الرئيس هو بنفسه هو ناتج عمليه
ديمقراطيه
وهذه هي القاعده وهذا هو ما يتوافق مع
النظام الاسلوب الحديث للحكم
الديمقراطيه امر جيد من الجيد طبعا الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيه بكل وسائل لكن في اختيار
ما هو العمل نقوم به لابد ان ناخذ بالنظر
لاعتبار عده عوامل مهمه
اي علينا ان نضع بعض الحدود على كل وسيله
او طريقه لتحقيق
المساله الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
وردي ما هي الحدود والوسائل
السؤالاتيه السؤال هو عن الادوات التي
تمتلكها اكواس من اجل تحقيق او ارساء
الديمقراطيه ومحاربه الانقلابات خاصه
بعدما قال رئيس نيجيريا بنفسه لن ننتظر
انقلابا بعد الاخر
كما قلت سابقا
ان نضع الاهداف الاستراتيجيه شيء ولكن ما
يقدر عن ذلك عند مدرسه خيارات
الاستراتيجيه وماده توفرها لتحقيق الوصول
الى ذلك الهدف او البعثه او المهمه لحد
الان شهدنا لاكواس قد
نشرت
بذلت جهود كبيره دبلوماسيه شاهدنا نوع من
الدراسيه المكوكيه وبنوع من الوساطه
ومحاوله
التواصل مع النخبه الاقلابيه العسكريين
هناك ولكن اعتقد هناك ضروره هو متابعه
الجهود الدبلوماسيه
واعتقد ان الهدف يتحقق بشكل افضل عن طريق
هذا الخليط من القوى الجهود الدبلوماسيه
بدلا من التفكير باستخدام القوه هذا هو
رئيس سيد عبد الله ابو بكر
السلطات الانقلابيه او المجلس العسكري
يقول بانه مستعد للتفاوض اكواس بشكل واضح
وصريح رفضت فتره انتقاليه لمده ثلاث سنوات
ما هي النقاط التي يمكن الوصول اليها
كتسويه ما بماذا يمكن ان تقبل السلطات في
النيجر
انا اعتقد انها بما ان السلطات قد طالبت
بثلاث سنوات كمده فتره انتقاليه وهذا ما
عرضوه على ممثلي الاقواس الذين جاؤوا
جمال عبد السلام فان الاقوى سيقولون انهم
لا يمكن ان يقبلوا ثلاث سنوات اولا هذا
كان مجرد اقتراح من المجلس العسكري
وكذلك المجلس يقول انه سوف
سوف يدعون الى مؤتمر شامل لكل النيجرى من
بعد في خلال فتره شهر من الزمن وانذاك يتم
تقرير مده الفتره الانتقاليه ونظرا للمهام
الحكومه الانتقاليه وكلما تقوم به انا
اعتقد انهم فكره الثلاثه سنوات هذا امر
قابل للتفاوض ما ينبغي فهمه هو المهم هو
انه كان هناك انقلاب 23 من الشهر لكن في
الاسبوع الذي بعده ووضع وضع الاكواس
خطا احمرا عالي جدا اما ثلاث سنوات مقترح
من الانقلابيين والكل يقولون ان
الاجتماع الوطني الشامل
هم اللي قانون الفطره هي ثلاث سنوات او
اقل واقفه
لابد من
الاستماع الى ما يقوله المجلس العسكري
الاجتماع القادم يعني
الرئيس النيجيريا رمت الكره في ملعب
السلطات الانقلابيه عندما قال اذا لم
تستجب هذه السلطات سيفتح ذلك الباب لاطراف
خارجيه للتدخل
يرجى اعاده طرح السؤال لسيد عبد الله هذا
السؤال
نعم سيد عبد الله
نعم هذا واضح اليوم الجميع يعلمون
نحن نعرف ذلك في نيجيريا ان هناك تدخل
خارجي
من خارج افريقيا
الواقع هو فرنسا هي التي يدها موجوده في
كل ما يحصل في المنطقه
الثروات وغناء لجهر هي ما تريد فرنسا دوما
الاستمرار في نهبه وسرقته والسيطره على
دولتنا نعم كان هناك انقلاب في مالي كان
هناك انقلاب في بوركينا وغيرها ولم تطرح
اطلق في الحياه السابقه اي اقتراح لمساله
استعمال القوه ولكن في حالتنا يوم السبت
بعد انقلاب الاربعه
طرحت مباشره فكره فكره تهديد استخدام
العمل العسكري هذا امر غير مقبول
وبالتالي اذا كان هناك قبل ذلك
وخاصه مع البيان الصدر عن مجلس العسكري
الذي يطلب من السفير السفير الفرنسي
مغادره بلاد اعلنوا
اعلن العسكر
بعد فرنسا تتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
البلادنا ولا يعود الى فرنسا ان تعرف من
هو شرعي وغير شرعي
النيجريون هم الذين يعرفون ذلك اليوم قرر
الشعب والمجلس ان المجلس الهيئه الرسميه
اسمح لي
ان اسيد هذه يعني من
المقصود اخرى او الاطراف الخارجيه
باختصار لو سمحت
تحدث الرئيس النيجيريا عن اطراف خارجيه ما
المقصود بها
نعم
اذا كان حديثكم عن تدخل خارجي
فهذا يعني في حاله استخدام القوه العسكريه
طبعا نحن نعلم ان هناك تدخل في النيجر من
قبل عده دول فرنسا هناك امريكا هناك
الروس لمصالح هناك
وبالتالي
المصالح الاقتصاديه والامنيه موجوده في
بلاد في النيجر وبالتالي اذا ما حصل اي
استخدام للقوه
ان هذه النصائح وهذه الدولدها دور تقوم به
في الرد او الاستجابه الى اي استخدام
للقوه العسكريه
الحديثه حتى الدول المجاوره لنيجر مالي
بوركينا فاسو وغينيا
والجزائر كلها دول قد عرضت الانضمام
والحركه الدبلوماسيه التي تجري شكرا لك
سيد هذه للاسف انتهى الوقت هذا الرئيس
السابق للتطوير الدفاعي بوزاره الدفاع
النيجيريه وزميل كليه الدفاع الوطني في
نيجيريا وشكرا للسيد عبد الله ابو بكر
رئيس منظمه النيجر اولا من اليامي
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
تدخل العسكري المحتمل في النيجر ونسال ضيف
الحصاد عن طبيعه المخاطر والصعوبات التي
قد تواجه هذا التدخل
[موسيقى]
قال مصدر عسكري ان حريقا اندلع في مستودع
لوقود الطائرات في مطار الخرطوم الدولي
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات في مدن الخرطوم
تفقد رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان جرح الجيش في المستشفى العسكري
بعطبره في هذه الاثناء دعت الخارجيات
والامريكيه الى وقف القتال فورا والسماح
بمرور جميع المدنيين الى خارج نياله واكدت
على وجوب محاسبه مرتكبي الفضائع
[موسيقى]
سماء الخرطوم غير الصافيه منذ شهور انعجاف
هذا الدخان ناجم عن حريق بمستودع وقود
الطائرات في المطار الدولي للعاصمه
السودانيه من اين للدخان ان يغيب عن
المشهد في بلد يتمدد فيه الاقتتال ولا
يتوقف شهدت الساعه الاخيره الماضيه معارك
ضاريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
عده مناطق من الخرطوم قصف الطائره الجيش
السوداني اهدافا للدعم السريع في منطقه
سوبا شرق العاصمه انباء عن قصف قوات الدعم
بالصواريخ من مواقع تمركزها في الخرطوم
بحري اهدافا للجيش النظامي وسط مدينه ام
درمان وسط كل فوضى السلاح خرج ومنذ الخامس
الماضي قائد الجيش ورئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان من مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه الذي قال خصومه انه تحت
الحصار حتى الرحال في بورتسودان العاصمه
المؤقته للحكومه في شهور الحرب بين الاخوه
الاعداء استنادا لصور نشرت الجمعه تفقد
البرهان جرح الجيش في المستشفى المركزي
لمدينه عطبره في ولايه نهر النيل شملت
جوله البرهان الاولى خارج الخرطوم ومنذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل قاعده للسلاح
المدفعيه في المنطقه وقبلها اندرمان
الجوله الاهم ربما سياسيا هي تلك المقرره
خارج البلاد هل ستنتهي بخطوه ولو محتشمه
تجاه حل خارج اطار السلاح للازمه الراهنه
الوساطه السابقه لم تحقن الدماء ولم تردم
هو الخلافات بين الطرفين المتناحرين
الصراع يهدد السودان بان يطيح به كاملا
التحذير كان على لسان منسق الامم المتحده
لشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جريفيث اوضح ان طول
امد النزاع في السودان قد يدفع المنطقه
بكاملها الى كارثه انسانيه يراقب العالم
من يشري ويعلق ببيانات شجب ووعيد احيانا
دون ان يغير ذلك في تطورات النزاع شيئا
تعطي الخارجيه الامريكيه الطرفين الى وقف
القتال فورا والسماح بمرور جميع المدنيين
بامان خارج نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب كردفان
تحدث البيان عن ضروره محاسبه مرتكبي
الفضائع في السودان ودان تفشي العنف
الجنسي في غرب دارفور ومناطق اخرى
تختلط الحسابات الشخصيه بالخارجيه
والاقليميه في صراع مسلح على ارض السودان
يتهوى فيه بسرعه مخيفه ما بقي من بنيه
تحتيه ومؤسسات والاهم من وحده شعب سئم
تكاليف حروب داخليه واخرى بالوكاله
ينضم الينا من لندن خالد الايسر الكاتب
والمحلل السياسيه السوداني سيد خالد
جوله البرهان الى خارج الخرطوم
اهلا بك يا استاذه فداوى مشاهديكم الكرام
دلالات زياره البرهان الى خارج الخرطوم
كثيره وربما ابرزها انه لم يعد محاصرا كما
كانت الدعم السريع منذ اشهر من القطط
بالتاكيد هذه اولى الدلالات ولكن الدلالات
الاكبر ان البرهان الان يريد ان يرتب
ويوفق اوضاع الدوله السودانيه في التوازن
على عمل العسكري وتعلمين ان قوات الدعم
السريعه المتمرده انتهت نهيا واضحه منذ
الساعات الاولى في انها احرقت عدد من
مستودعات الغذاء والادويه كما حدث في
مستودع اليونسيف في دارفور عندما حرقت 100
يورو عليه
التطعيم شارع الاطفال وكذلك كل المصانع
والاسواق في كل المناطق التي دخلتها هي
كانت تريد ان تلعب كرت التضييق على معاش
الناس في السودان حتى يعني يصير ذلك واحد
من اسباب الضغط على المؤسسه العسكريه
لتلبيه الشروط المطلوبه ايضا هناك الدوله
البرهان
ستمتد الى التواصل الدولي مع الدول
الاقليم للوصول الى نوع من الدعم الخارجي
وتوضيح الرؤيه الوطنيه السودانيه ممثله في
القوات المسلحه السودانيه عدد من الاشياء
المهمه وايضا حاله الترحيب الكبرى التي
قامت بها الشعب السوداني هذا الخروج
والزهور العلني بعد انقطاع طويل في مناطق
غير الخرطوم ذكرتها سيد خالد لابد من
التوقف عندها عندما تقول ان البرهان سيرتب
اوضاع الدوله السياسيه والعسكريه ما
المقصود بذلك ترتيب اوضاع الدوله سياسيا
وعسكريا كيف سيرتب ذلك
دعينا نوضح جزئيه مهمه للغايه هناك كثير
جدا من الحالمين في بعض القوى السياسيه
التي كانت اساس لهذا الحريق الذي اندلع في
السودان هي الان تعول على فكره الدخول عبر
بوابات الحوار من جديد ولكن هذا الامر
اقصد هو اعلان الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي على وجه التحديد والخصوص هم
يجتهدوا كثيرا عندما تبرز اخبار وعناوين
عريضه في ما جرى في جده من التوافقات
والتفاهمات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
سياق اعلان جده او اتفاق جدا الذي انتهي
الى الهدنه التي لم تنجح اول ما تخرج مثل
هذه الاخبار هم يخرجون تصريحا وتشاهدينهم
ينتشرون عبر ساحات الاعلام والفضائي
والتليفزيونات والسوشيال ميديا لكي يحجزوا
مقعدا متقدما في عمليه الحوار وهذه لعبه
اصبحت مكشوفه لدى الشعب السوداني المؤكد
هنا ان الجيش وحده مع كل التاكيد على ان
نقدم تضحيات كبيره جدا واستشهد من عدد من
افراده دفاعا عن الوطن ولكن الاراده
الغالبه هي صوت الجماهير هناك مكون من 40
مليون مواطن سوداني لن يقبل من جديد انت
سيد تتسيد المرحله الانتقاليه
المجلس المركزيه ولكن السيد مالك عقار
نائب السيد البرهان عندما وضع خريطه
طريق وتحدث عن تسويه قال بان الجميع
سيشارك في الحوار بعد المرحله الانتقاليه
ولكن الجميع لن يشارك في حكومه انتقاليه
هو ذكر ان الجميع سيشاركون في حوار يتداول
امر الامه السودانيه وتاسيس دوله المواطنه
مخاطبه القضايا والمشكلات الاساسيه التي
انتهت بالناس وانزلقت بالبلاد لهذه
المعارك لكن المشاركه هذه تعني مشاركه
مرحله ما بعد الفتره الانتقاليه اكبر
مشاكل السودان التي ظهرت وتسببت في انسداد
الافقيه مشاركه غواه سياسيه بعينها دون
تفويض شعبيه خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
النقطه الاخيره التي ذكرت هو التواصل
الدولي
هل سنتوقع جوله للسيد البرهان خارج
السودان
بكل تاكيد سيكون هناك جوله للبرهان
وتعلمين ان هناك بعض القوه الاقليميه
ساهمت في عمليه الدفع باتجاه ان تصل
بالسودان الى توافق وطني السوداني يبطي
يطوي ستار على على هذه الازمه بالتاكيد
جوله البرهان ايضا فيها رسائل المجتمع
الدولي الذي
تمارسة الايجاد بكلمه واحده لو سمحت بكل
واحده مصر والسعوديه هم الاغرب الى اي
زيارات محترمه ولكن الرساله هنا ان
المجتمع الدولي لو سمحتي للمجتمع الدولي
هو تعامل بازدواجيه مع السودان الق
الامريكي الان اصبح مختطف في قرار سيادي
يريد ان يرجح كفه الدعم السريع وبعض القوه
المدنيه وهذا امر مرفوض ان كانوا يريدون
السودان لماذا لم يرسلوا الغذاء كما
ارسلوه السوداني
من لندن شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
فاستعدادا لما سمي بمعركه الشتاء القادم
موافقه صحيفه الجارديان فان قاده في النت
وبحثوا مع قائد الجيش الاوكراني اعاده ضبط
استراتيجيه كافي العسكريه وتقديم الدعم في
الهجوم المضاده في المقابل اكد نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي
ان المواجهه هي الخيار الوحيد لكونها حربا
وجوديه بالنسبه لروسيا وعلى الارض تستمر
حرب المسيرات بين الجانبين
حرب روسيا واوكرانيا مستمره في اطار حرب
المسيرات بين البلدين اعلنت روسيا السبت
اسقاط ثلاث سيارات اوكرانيه كانت احداها
تقترب من موسكو واثنتان في المنطقه
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا بينها واحده في شيبي
كينو بمنطقه بيلفورود
بينما قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها
دمرت مسيرتين من نوع الشاهد في مقاطعه
خارك كيف شمال شرقي البلاد من ناحيه ثانيه
اعلنت قياده المنطقه الوسطى في الجيش
الروسي صدها سبع هجمات اوكرانيه في اتجاه
ليمن واستهداف نحو 20 موقعا للمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه في المنطقه
كيف تؤكد استمرارها في هجماتها المضاده
ويتحدث قادتها العسكريون عن اختراق ما
يصفه باصعب خطوط الدفاع الروسيه بمنطقه في
الجنوب وانها ستتمكن الان وفي المستقبل من
التقدم بسرعه اكبر ربما في اشاره الى
استمرار الدعم الغربي
وفي هذا الاطار نقلت صحيفه الجارديان
البريطانيه عن مصادر دفاعيه واخرى مطلعه
النقاده العسكريين الكبار في حلف الناتو
بحثوا مع قائد الجيش الاوكراني المساعده
في التقدم في هجومها المضاد الراهن واعاده
ضبط استراتيجيه كييف العسكريه وتركيز
الضربات على جبهه زابولوجيا تمهيدا لقطع
الطرق الامداد نحو القرم وتقول
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان الهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني وضع القوات الروسيه تحت الضغط
في باخموت وجنوب البلاد واين القوات
الروسيه تواصل هجماتها على نطاق محدود في
الشمال الشرق في قطاع كوبيانيس كريمان
وحققت تقدما محدودا بالنسبه لروسيا فان
حربها في اوكرانيا تعتبر صراعا وجوديا
وقال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي بمتر
ميدف ان خصوم بلا ده في الغرب يدفعون
الجميع نحو حرب عالميه ثالثه ودعاهم
للتخلي عن سعيهم لهزيمه روسيا او تمزيقها
وبينما تستمر تطورات وتداعيات الحرب على
الارض ويزداد الحديث عن ذلك وعن احتمالات
التصعيد المرتقبه يغيب الحديث او يكاد عن
الاشاره ولو لبارقه امل يمكن ان تقود
لانهاء الحرب
ومعنا من اثرنار فاسال باند وزير الدفاع
النمساويه السابقه اهلا بك
صحيفه الجارديان تتحدث عن لقاء جامعه قاده
من الناتو مع قائد اركان الجيش الاوكراني
دعوا فيه الى الضبط استراتيجيات او اعاده
ضبط استراتيجيات العسكريه اعاده ضبطها في
اي اتجاه
اعتقد ان اوكرانيا عليها ان تقرر بنفسها
اي نوع من الاستراتيجيه
ترغبها
وترغب باستخدامها في هذه الحرب لانه في كل
نصيحه
ستكون مرحب بها لكن يبقى الامر عائدا لهم
بانفسهم لانه فقط عندما تكون المعلومات
متوفره بشكل كامل والخبره الكامله للقتال
انذاك فقط يمكن اتخاذ القرارات الصحيحه
طبعا هناك الان مناقشات حول هذه الحرب لان
الهجوم المضاد بدا في الشهر في الرابط من
يونيو حزيران قبل حوالي ثلاثه اشهر وحتى
بدايه الشتاء في اوكرانيا
تبقى فتره قصيره شهرين او ثلاثه لا اكثر
وبالتالي يمكن
يمكن تكون هذه الفتره حاسمه او المرحله ما
قبل الحسم
وبالتالي في النقاشات لهذا السبب بدات
الان سيد يعني كيف تقيم الهجوم المضاد او
ما عرف بهجوم الربيع ونحن بدانا نتحدث عن
هجوم الشتاء
ما الذي حققه هذا الهجوم
الوافي
انه عاده في الحروب ان
لبين سيحاولان
تحسين قدراتهم وادائهم
وتجاوز نقاط الضعف على الارجاح في فتره
الشتاء
هناك بعض الميزه للجانب الاوكراني نظرا
للمنظومات السلاح الحديثه الغربيه التي
سيحصلون عليها
والجانب اخر الجانب الروسي ايضا يمكن ان
يمارس كثير من ضبط النفس لدى جنوده
ويحسن اداء قواته والذي كان بالتاكيد
الجانب الضعيف ونقطه الضعف في
في السنه والنصف الماضيه
شكرا لك من اثينا فارنار فاسلافند وزير
الدفاع النمساويه السابق
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
في تغطيه هذه القضيه وانتظار استكمال
التحقيقات الجاريه ورفض بسكوب ان يتطرق
لاي معلومات بشان مستقبل مجموعه فاغنر
مشيرا الى انه لا وجود قانونيا لشركه
فاغندر العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا قال وزير الدفاع
ان وفاه بريجوجن اضعفت الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين واضاف ريزنكوفا ان مقتل
بريجوجن كشف كيف يقوم بوتين بعقد اتفاق مع
شخص ما ثم ينقلب على هذا الاتفاق وقال
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان مسؤولي الكريم
على حد وصفه
اصدار الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
مرسوما بالزامي عناصر المجموعات المسلحه
غير النظاميه باداء قسم التعهد بالاخلاص
والوفاء لروسيا الذي جاء بعد قرابه شهرين
على تمرد فاغنر يعيد تسليط الضوء على
شركات الامنيه والعسكريه الخاصه في روسيا
وتشير تقارير الى ان عدد تلك الشركات يقدر
باكثر من 70 شركه وتتطلع باعمال قتاليه في
اوكرانيا ومهام اخرى في عدد من دول العالم
مع انها الاشهر والاكثر تاثيرا لكن فاجنر
لم تكن الشركه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
الوحيده قبل الحرب على اوكرانيا وخلالها
برزت عشرات الشركات الاخرى التي كان لها
حضور في الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا وفي
دول اخرى
من تلك الشركات ار اس بي للحراسات الخاصه
وتعرف نفسها بانها تعمل وفقا للقوانين
الروسيه ومعتمده من مؤتمر جينيف الدولي
لمقدمي الخدمات الامنيه وتختص بحمايه
السفن وعقور النفط والغاز والطاقه وحمايه
كبار الشخصيات
اما فشركه اسسها متقاعدون من القوات
الخاصه الروسيه وقد فرضت عليها عقوبات
امريكيه في نيسان ابريل الماضي وهناك شركه
ريدوت التي اسست على يد مظليين روس سابقين
وتعمل على توفير الامن للهيئات الحكوميه
الروسيه في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
مجموعه انتيرور وقد شكلت من ضباط سابقين
خدموا في القوات الخاصه الروسيه او القوات
المحموله جوا او مشاه البحريه شركه غاز
بروم ابرز شركات الطاقه الروسيه وبترخيص
من الحكومه انشات شركه امنيه خاصه بها احد
مكوناتها يسمى
في معارك باوكرانيا كذلك شركه استوم
من اثرياء روسن وشركات كبيره في قطاع
المواد الخام لم تكتمل التشريعه القانونيه
الروسيه لتنظيم عمل هذه الشركات واضافه
الشرعيه الكامله ويبدو ان السبب هو عدم
رغبه موسكو في تحمل تبعات اعمال تلك
الشركات خارج الاراضي الروسيه
[موسيقى]
حضر المسؤولون في اقليم البنجاب شرقي
باكستان من ارتفاع جديد لمنسوبي نهر
ستوليتج خلال اليومين المقبلين مع استمرار
الهند في تصريف كميات كبيره من المياهفيه
وقالت اداره الريف اقليم البنجاب ان مستوى
تدفق المياه في هذا النهر المشترك مع
الهند تسبب خلال الايام الماضيه بفيضانات
الحقت اضرارا كبيره بمئات القرى وادت الى
اجلاء نحو 100 الف كروي من 6 محافظات في
الاقليم
تستمر المعاناه هنا في اقليم البنجاب
للاسبوع الرابع على التوالي مع استمرار
تدفق المياه الى الكثير من الحقول
الزراعيه والى الكثير من القرى في ست
محافظات هنا في اقليم البنجاب التجول
بواسطه قارب في هذه الطرقات المغموره
بالمياه بين البيوت القرويه تعطي فرصه
لمشاهده بعض القرويين الذين ربما لم
يغادروا بيوتهم او ربما تمكنوا من العوده
اليها لاسباب مختلفه بعض من هؤلاء لم
يغادر منزله لمحاوله المحافظه على امتعته
مخافه ان تتعرض للسرقه او ما شابه فيما ان
اخرين تمكنوا من العوده ربما لجلب بعض
الامتعه او ربما لتزويد من تبقى داخل هذه
البيوت القرويه ببعض المواد الغذائيه بين
هذه القرى والداخل البيوت القرويه الكثير
من المشاهدات حقيقه فيما يتعلق حجم الدمار
الذي لحق بهذه البيوت القرويه البسيطه
بالتاكيد كل المزارع المحيطه بتركيا القرى
وكل الاراضي الزراعيه والحقول تدمرت بشكل
كامل مع انغمار المياه بشكل كبير في كل
هذه الحقول المحيطه بتلك القرى التي يزيد
عددها عن اكثر من 500 وثمانين قريه لكن
الاحوال حقيقه داخل هذه البيوت او داخل
ازقه هذه القرى وبين البيوت القرويه مؤلمه
للغايه وهو ما يعكس بالتاكيد جانبا من حجم
الماسات هنا في اقليم البنجاب عبد الرحمن
مطر الجزيره اقليم البنجاب
بدات شركه توتال وشركهها الايطاليه وقطر
للطاقه انشطتها لاستكشافيه للغاز والنفط
واعمال الحفر في الرقعه رقم تسعه من
المياه البحريه الجنوبي لبنان
بحثا عن الغاز
هناك في الرقعه التاسعه من المياه
الجنوبيه تربط منصه التنقيب
هي رحله استكشاف انتظرها لبنان سنوات قبل
ان يحسمها اتفاق ترسيم الحدود البحريه مع
اسرائيل العام الماضي نتائجها قد تكون
واعده وفق الخبراء فهنا في جنوب شرق
المتوسط تتمركز معظم الاكتشافات التجاريه
موقع الحفر
يعني ان شاء الله
من ناحيه تحسين التصنيف السيادي للبلد من
ناحيه تصنيف تحسين السقا بالاستثمار
بالبلد
لبنان استعد لوجستيان سلطاته تنظر
بايجابيه الى الرقعه رقم تسعه وتتطلع الى
كميات وافره من الغاز بالاستناد الى
المسوحات
الجيولوجيهي
متوسط الحجم مش كثير كبير بس مش صغير
وبيسمح بانتاج تجاري اقله يستفيد منه
لبنان على مستوى صناعه الكهرباء وصناعه
الاخرى والاستعمال يمكن المنزلي وممكن
نوصل لموضوع تصدير الغاز بس هيدا بده بنى
تحتيه مختلفه واستثمارات اكبر
لكنها الاستثمارات تحتاج الى استقرار
سياسي تفتقده البلاد نتيجه الشهور في
رئاسه الجمهوريه ووجود حكومه تصريف اعمال
وغياب الاصلاحات والخلافات التي تؤخر
اقرار الصندوق السيادي لاداره عائدات
النفط اضافه الى التوتر الدائم مع اسرائيل
انه لبنان ينتقل من الاستكتشاف الى
الانتاج هذا قرار ليس محليا هذا قرار دولي
اقليمي هذا اذا كان في كميات قاعده تجاريه
اما اذا قيل للبنان ما في كميه تجاريه
اعتقد اننا سنذهب الى سيناريو كاريش اللي
كان في توتر كتير كبير بين حزب الله وبين
اسرائيل وبالتالي عوض على بدء وفيما يستمر
التوتر جنوبا مع اسرائيل هناك خشيه من
تطورات قد تعرقل مسار البحث عن الغاز
والنفط في ضوء ما يصفه لبنان بالاطماع
الاسرائيليه بارضه ومياهه
رغم بقاء احتمال التصعيد مع اسرائيل واردا
في اي لحظه تبدي السلطات هنا تفاؤلا
باكتشاف غاز في مياه الجنوب ينعش اقتصاد
البلاد تفاؤل تقابله هواجس لدى اللبنانيين
من تسليم الثروه التي قد تختزنها هذه
الاعماق الى سلطه يتهمها كثيرون بالفساد
وبتبديد الثروات
كاترين حنا الجزيره بيروت
مع استمرار ازمه النيجر تقول مجموعه
واقواس ان الخيار العسكريه لا يزال مطروحا
على الطاوله بينما امر قاده الانقلاب قوات
الجيش بالبقاء في حاله تاهب فما هي
امكانيه التدخل العسكري ومخاطرها نبدا
باستعراض الموقع
بمساحتها الممتده على مليون و 270 الف
كيلو متر مربع تتصدر النيجر دول منطقه غرب
افريقيا من حيث المساحه وتتقاسم حدودا
بريه مع ليبيا والجزائر ومالي وبوركينا
فاسو وبنين ونيجيريا وتشاد ايضا تقع
نيجيريا جنوب النيجر وهي صاحبه اطول حدود
معها رئيس نيجيريا الذي يتولى الرئاسه
الدوليه للمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس استهل مهامه بالقول لن نسمح
بانقلاب بعد اخر في غرب افريقيا تشاد
الواقعه شرقا نيجر
التي تاتي ثانيا في طول الحدود معها اعلنت
انها لن تشارك في اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر
موقف مماثل صدر من الجزائر وهي الجار
الشمالي الاكبر للنيجر بحدود تبلغ نحو الف
كيلو متر ليبيا التي تقع شمال شرقي النيجر
سبق ان عانت من تداعيات عدم الاستقرار في
النيجر بنين الواقع جنوب النيجر قالت انها
تفضل حلا دبلوماسيا لكنها اكدت دعم مواقف
اكواس ماذا عن ماله وبوركينا فاسو ينفرد
البلد بموقفهما الداعم للانقلاب منذ
اعلانه ورفضهما الشديد للجوء الى الخيار
العسكري وسبق ان حذرته في بيان مشترك من
ان اي تدخل عسكريا في النيجر سيتم الرد
عليه
كانت المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس قد اعلنت تفعيل قوه نحت
الاحتياط غير ان خبراء يشككون في امكانيه
شني عمليه عسكريه يصفونها بانها عاليه
المخاطر ويصعب تنفيذها
تكلف اكواس قوه الاحتياط بمهمات على
ارتباط بحفظ السلام وسبق النشرتها في
سيراليون وليبيريا وغينيا بيساو وجامبيا
لكن المنظمه الاقليميه وبحسب خبراء لم
تتوافق يوما على نوع المهام المحدده لهذه
القوات
السنغال وبنين ونيجيريا وكوت ديفوار اعلنت
استعدادها لارسال قوات لكن وحدها كوت
ديفوار اوضحت حتى الان عدد القوات التي
يمكن ارسالها لمثل هذا التدخل وهو الف
عسكري
ماذا عن الصعوبات في حال سنه هجوم بريس
ستطار قوات دول غرب افريقيا الى عبور مئات
الكيلومترات من الاراضي المعاديه نذكر هنا
بان مالي وبوركينا فاسو حضرتا اكواس من ان
اي تدخل في النيجر سيكون بمثابه اعلان حرب
بل ان قاده الانقلاب في نيام اعلن منذ
يومين تفويض قوات مالي وبوركينا فاسو دخول
النيجر ان تعرضت لهجوم
وسيشكل الحرس الجمهوري الذي تصدر الانقلاب
ويضم 700 عنصر سيشكل محور اي مقاومه غير
ان استعداد الوحدات الاخرى في جيش النيجر
للقتال في حال وقوع تدخل تبقى موضع جدل
وحول هذا الموضوع معنا مارتن ايوي سيد
مارتن في ظل المعطيات التي تحدثنا عنها
والصعوبات التي يمكن ان تواجه اي تدخل
عسكري برايك ما مدى واقعيه التلبيح بهذا
الخيار
نعم فعلا
اسعدتم مساء
واسعد الله مساء
مشاهديكم
ان
مجموعه دول الغربي افريقيا تواجه في
الحقيقه حيره خطيره وهذه الحيره مصدرها
انها عندما قاموا بالرد على هذا الانقلاب
قاموا
بتهديد نشره قوات عسكريه
لاعاده النظام الدستوري وهذا هذا القرار
الواقع لم يكن قد جرت التفكير به مليا
فبعد هذا الاعلان المنطقه كلها حاولت ان
تفكر بما هي
الامكانيات نشر قوات في النيجر
وقد وجدوا بان هناك صعوبات كثيره في هذا
الامر فاولا ليس هناك جانب او او مجال
اي فقره في وثائق الاكواس بان على ان يشرق
قوات عسكريه لاستعاده الديمقراطيهم عند
يحصلين انقلاب هو ان البروتوكول الاضافي
حول الديمقراطيه وهو ما تستخدمه في هذه
الحاله لا يعطي هذه الولايه لاكواس
واهم كل ذلك فان هذا البروتوكول لا يحدد
او يعرف ما هو معنى الانقلاب لا يعرف ما
هو التغييرات غير الدستوريه وما المقصود
بها في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي هذا يعني
هناك ضعف في هذا الاعلان والان نشر قوات
في النيجر سيكون دون نتائج التبعات كثيره
خاصه من الجانب الانساني
تتساءل حاليا هل حقيقه انه من الضروري
اطلاقه او بدء حرب جديده في المنطقه وهل
حقا من الضروري حلقه
كارثه انسانيه في المنطقه وهي منطقه
شاهدنا فيها اكثر ما ينبغي وازال فيها
اكثر ما اكثر اكثر من الظروف الاوضاع ذات
الطلب مساعدات انسانيه وهي بفضيعه وتبتلي
اي نشر قوات الفن سيؤدي الى المزيد من
من الظروف الانسانيه القاسيه التي لا
تواجهها والنتائج والتبع ستكون ابعد بكثير
من
مارتن نعود الى قوه الاحتياط وفق اي اليه
تتشكل قوه الاحتياط من يقوم بتمويل قوه
الاحتياط يعني على ماذا يقع او اي دوله كل
دوله بكم تساهم من ضمن قوه الاحتياط هل
هنالك نصوص واضحه فيما يتعلق بقوه
الاحتياط هذه واليات
[موسيقى]
هذه القوه احتياط التابع
الاكواسكن على شكل كتيبه
لواء وربما يكونوا اكثر
هذه قوه احتياط في الواقع بدا العمل بها
في 2003
ولكن تلك القوه ما زالت في حاله تكوين وان
اكواس مناطق القليله في العالم التي نجحت
بتاسيس مثل هذه القوه الاحتياط التي يمكن
تعبئتها وتنشيطها بسرعه ونشرها خلال
الفتره قصيره من الزمن وهذا هو ما شاهدناه
لحد الان في
اجتماعات العسكريين
هيئات الاركان الذين
اجتمعوا في مناسبتين او ثلاثه في اكره
عاصمه
[موسيقى]
هناك فعلا مجال او اطار للتدخل العسكري
اللي من قبل هذه القوه الاحتياط التي
اسسها التي مبنيه على قوه الاحتياط
الاتحاد الافريقي
نيجيريا هي من اكبر الدول المساهمه في قوه
الاحتياط هذه انت ذكرت وما نعرفه بانه
هنالك معارضه حتى في نيجيريا من تدخل
عسكري في حال لم تساهم نيجيريا في هذه
القوه هل تستطيع الدول الاخرى سد العجز
هذا سيكون في غايه الصعوبه فناجيريا هي
الدوله الرئيسيه فيما يتعلق بتكوين هذه
وقياده هذه القوه او تتمتع بخبره طويله
بدءا من نشر القوات في بدايه التسعينيات
لايقاف
المذابح التي كانت حاصره اثناء الحرب
الاهليه هناك وبالتالي نيجيريا اصبحت
تتمتع بخبره كبيره فيما يتعلق بين نشره
القوات الاكواس الاحتياط
والان لو اننا جدع لم تشارك في هذه القوه
لا اعتقد ان الدول يمكن دول اخرى ان تشرق
وقتها ليس بلدا صغيرا في النيجر بلد كبير
جدا حتى اكثر من نيجيريا
فتصور لو ان الدول الاخرى لو استطاعت ان
نشرب قواتتها المطلوبه فان الاستعلى ثقه
بان بان الدول الاخرى يمكن ان تعبئ او
تجنده ما من جنود اللازمين لنشرهم في
النيجر بشكل فعال النجار الغاليه
التي
مثل هذا الامر الكثير من اجرين لا
نيجيريين لا يتغنى بلادهم مستعد للدخول في
حرب وكثير من الناس يعتقون ليست الدوله
ينبغي ان نحافظها بسبب قربها
وتقاربها الثقافي
والصلاه الثقافيه بين البلدين كبير
الباحثين في المعهد الافريقي للدراسات
الامنيه
[موسيقى]
يظل استكشاف الفضاء يراود البشريه من جيل
الى اخر الثاني عشر من ابريل عام 1961
شهيده اول رحله بشريه فضائيه عندما انطلق
السوفيتي يوري جاجرين الى الفضاء الخارجي
ليفتح بذلك السبيل امام استكشاف الفضاء
بما فيه نفع للانسانيه وقبل ساعات اطلقت
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ومؤسس ومؤسسه
سبايس اكس المركبه الفضائيه كرو 7 التي
تحمل اربعه رواد الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
بقياده الامريكيه من اصل ايراني ياسمين
مقبلي ومعه دنماركي ويابني وايضا تجارب
علميه من بينها جما عينات خلال عمليه
الخروج الى الفضاء لمعرفه ما اذا كانت
المحطه تطلق كائنات حيه دقيقه من خلال
فتوحات الهواء لنظام حفظ الحياه على متن
المحطه ونقلا عن مدير ناسا سيق اكثر من
200 تجربه علميه تحضيرا لمهمات الى القمر
والمريخ وما بعدهما دعونا ننتظر ونرى ختام
الحصاد شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]